A background as a children's performer
and drawing inspiration from Mr. Bean? The
person behind Art the Clown's heavy makeup
looks completely different out of costume.
Pennywise isn't the only circus performer killing
it in the horror genre these days. In fact,
Pennywise's reputation as the scariest
clown in pop culture is arguably being
contested by another haunting persona that is
reportedly causing audiences to faint and vomit
in movie theaters, per Evening Standard. The
critically acclaimed "Terrifier 2," directed
by Damien Leone, sees the return of
the seriously creepy Art the Clown.
The character first appeared in Leone's
2013 anthology flick "All Hallows Eve," in
which Art was played by Mike Giannelli. The
first full-length "Terrifier" film starring
David Howard Thornton as Art was unleashed
upon audiences in 2016. The end result was
an 86-minute gore-filled bloodbath of
terror featuring a nightmare-inducing
menace in the form of Art the Clown. The
low-budget feature may not have all the
bells and whistles of most big-name horror
flicks, but Leone somehow managed to max
out the mayhem in every frame, thanks
in part to well-crafted monster, Art.
The creepy clown killer has received significant
acclaim since his debut, with Farsighted claiming
that Art makes Stephen King's Pennywise look
more like Krusty the Clown from "The Simpsons."
"Hey kids!"
It goes without
saying that the actor behind the iconic makeup
deserves a lot of credit for helping director
Leone realize his goal of outdoing the first film
with the sequel. And after fans watched the ending
of "Terrifier 2," they may have been curious to
know what Art the Clown looks like out of costume.
Actor David Howard Thornton plays Art the
Clown in both "Terrifier" and "Terrifier
2." Thornton's career is made up of an assortment
of credits including theater and voice-over work,
which don't just involve homicidal clowning
around. He has appeared in the DC drama series
"Gotham," and has also done voice-over work
for the Hulu animated series "The Bravest
Knight." But after perusing his resume,
it quickly becomes clear that Thornton's
most notorious claim to fame to date is,
without a doubt, playing Art the Clown.
Much of the praise heaped upon
the "Terrifier" films recognize
both the hideous onscreen actions
of the vile face-painted killer,
and the actor playing him. Starburst Magazine
commended the frightful clown, writing,
"Art is a truly enigmatic and memorable
villain. He frequently veers into the
territory of being genuinely unpleasant
to watch, which makes him feel somewhat
separate from the stable of horror icons
such as Freddy Krueger and Chucky."
But the character can't take all of
the credit, and the publication also
praised Thornton's brilliant performance, writing,
"Special acknowledgment should be given to David
Howard Thornton for a truly wonderful performance
and one that easily stands toe-to-toe
with the likes of Curry and Skarsgård."
It might seem like playing a terrifying
clown murderer is the farthest thing away
from kid-friendly entertainment. But for Thornton,
his past work as a performer
for children came in handy.
Thornton revealed to Dread Central that he
scored the horrifying role by auditioning on
Actor's Access, with the call-out asking for tall
and skinny performers with clowning or physical
comedy experience. While Thornton was new to
clowning, physical comedy was in his wheelhouse,
and his years doing children's theater made him
stand out to the casting director. According to
Backstage, Thornton previously studied at
the Fantasy Playhouse Children's Theater in
Huntsville, Alabama, which unexpectedly
helped prepare him for the "Terrifier."
"I would honestly like to make one more
and have an idea for a solid trilogy."
Given that Art the Clown doesn't have any lines,
Thornton's physical comedy training came in very
handy. In addition to his children's theater
experience, he also drew inspiration from other
great physical comedians, such as Charlie Chaplin
and Rowan Atkinson, who plays Mr. Bean. Of course,
Thornton also based his performance on some
of the greatest horror actors of all time,
like Robert Englund, who played Freddy Krueger,
and Kane Hodder who portrayed Jason Voorhees.
All of these many influences perfectly came
together to create a truly killer clown.